introduces a more expansive universe I
like to talk about the marvel cinematic
multiverse there are other dimensions in
Doctor Strange and a lot of rear places
that they go hey don't get an idea of so
you gotta use of itself means go yeah
the whole doggone iet about
so maybe a question for you till it's
dark you know and Scott you you meant a
little bit you know why you've chosen
Qualcomm it's one of the portals for the
movie maybe Kevin might want to add on
to why you've chosen well you wanted the
movie to feel global and no place feels
more global in Hong Kong
[Applause]
have to say in Hong Kong just seemed
perfect
I got the young of aging as Yoda
[Applause]
or challenges did you face brings up the
strange did you relate to him in any
particular way
I
hope not I mean my life and I think my
parents are very different but
every single challenge you could
possibly hope to relish as an actor was
on offer with this role whether it be
fantastically juicy rich and detailed
scenes and an amazing character arc to
comedy to action to imagine it was it
sort of fulfilled everything that you
could imagine from a Marvel film its
biggest bulb and it's very new visually
obviously but also with some of the tone
of it and what a privilege to bring this
very special New York year / sorcerer to
life and with the most exceptional cars
being led by a wonderful director in
France Scott Derrickson under the eyes
of the world's greatest super fan Kevin
I mean it's a it's a winning team and I
hope it turns out well and people love
it as much as I enjoyed making it hi
woody you now you go hide and we're
gonna take the little one yeah but a
cute intern go Bible or something okay
with that video call signal so you know
that's all I do you know whether you get
four or five as a team what they do or
it's you talk like that fees until a
high get they already hold even little
you know what it counts are you Tibet
like have you ever
imagined playing it superhero that means
that a dream of yours to play a
superhero
[Applause]
it's the truth that happened and it's
not something I Harvard an ambition for
I I could joy being in the audience I've
enjoyed
for a long time I think since the first
superhero time I saw is Tim Burton's
Batman I miss her from that went in and
Marvel had just taken it all to another
level and you know I turn out like my
paper my ticket my by Michael and I sit
there and I have you know couple of
hours at mind-blowing entertainment and
yeah so it's not something over thought
I needed to realize but having done it
now
I
mean
as far as I know and I think that's a
bit of responsibility to live up to the
promise they've shown a new but what are
they having I suppose the whole thing I
mean you and I it was a great motivation
those I was really intrigued I went into
the source material I talked a lot to
Scott and hosted took after our first
conversations I was really hooked on the
idea and it's been a joy ride ever since
hi come on you doing it one was to do
that your teeth are better together and
before you go what do you look after you
yeah you completely don't worry it will
be okay with my music don't worry it's
happy nobody like it but you're thinking
you know but I go there they believe
that people are better quite a few
really important use of a teaser boy so
it should see how you can signal
integrity again we can chat with tiller
so now how did you decide to play at the
ancient one and how would you describe
your interpretation of the roller well
when Scot first started talking to me
about it I became so intrigued and and
we talked about somebody who is so old
and so wise that they are so relaxed and
light that they don't sweat any of the
small stuff or even any other needed
stuff they just don't sweat and they can
see it all and that was very tantalizing
for me couldn't resist it hi buddy I
don't think that you would see you while
you get it done okay CC exacty guy again
I said that tango consecrating oh
yeah how would I know I'm very relaxed
who is it was it difficult is there any
difficulty for you to believe this
character was a little difficult for me
to be relaxed because I'm very very lazy
no it was a delight I'm not gonna stand
here and say it was very difficult and
we suffered we didn't suffer at all we
had a ball it was just a dream to make
this film it was like a family feeling
and we're so proud of it
[Applause]
and then there was a portal and that you
took Benedict to walk through it and
that you came out to about Everest was a
pole freezing for some freezing for
mortals but not fathers
I
love you when I came here with that are
you took that you'll never get the idea
to organize our acting easy focus I'll
go come on Mike really I thought till
that the one you're not really if I were
you but no Benedict also don't you get
it so tisha with us you know is there a
most memorable scene
that you did loved playing in this movie
it's a tricky question this because I
don't want to spoil anything by talking
about a
scenery piloting favorites because you
know each each moment it could be a bit
of action which could be a split second
on-screen or possibly even can't happen
since film yeah but you know there was
some wire work that I did that really
was like test riding a fairground ride
oh yeah it's just a riot I thought this
idk to do this is his work I mean the
harness is interesting there are some
things to sort of manage with that it's
not it's more than what you normally
like to feel like we're anything but in
the feeling of emotion and benevolence
being airborne and gymnastic in the air
some of the speed of the movements was
was ready for anything but I might my
abiding memory is just laughing a lot
that is having a lot of fun when the
cameras weren't rolling on a couple
occasions when they were
but yeah and I'm just working with
extraordinary people doing the most
fantastically varied work from the quite
sequences
2:07 like that maybe we can still don't
fully understand you have a memorable
scene from so many and I can like
Benedict I don't want to spoil anything
but I will say that the fighting was fun
[Applause]
I good night you know I thought I saw it
to be of yours that you said that you
know in this from the comics to a movie
there's a lot of imagery and then you
said that you know with modern
technology and filming that you're able
to bring this time of ezel to the cinema
yeah the comics for the inspiration for
the film and we wanted to be loyal to
the comics as much as we could because
they're so good and not just the story
not just the character but the visuals
drawing by The Grapes artists feed bit
code those visuals are unlike anything
else that's been done in comic book
history so that was our main source of
inspiration and then we tried to go even
further than that and do things that
were original that you haven't seen
before
I recommend we go on while I mean it I
would take you tomorrow why I mean come
on could they do hey Vaughn tell you to
go buy things that I find those easy
like dunkey caption fo but I gotta be
told something I've got Scott do you
have a favorite seat do I have a
favorite thing uh this is the honest
truth my favorite scene is a dialogue
scene between the two of these actors
right here there's nothing that the last
thing that they have together in the
movie is probably my favorite scene
to you to me emotionally my face I go to
holding a Morgan hey so we look forward
to October 27 yeah the speed in cinemas
here in Hong Kong even earlier than us
so now you'll have a take up there buddy
okay so I like to invite for you to join
me over here I come to LA thank you I
thought when I don't know one day that I
took my music although I eat Enoch come
on there's a specific area
me
llamo
sonic but neither holy I get
my time donut are you going on cantide
you don't get sick like so we can have
to pick up Sara wait I've got it how
about three I like to invite all of you
to do the the signature pose
yeah
Tiger that's my Jonah Avonex all okay
right on
300 pretty so pretty girls I'm
sixteen okay we'll let the progress take
a picture first
could you hold on I'm gonna sort of do
that move a
[Applause]
little bit to your right please just
gonna move your hands down a little bit
yeah